absolutely
you bet okay so dr sema so
i i don't disagree with that there has
never been a study
in medicine and i've been in medicine 35
years i'm sure a long time like you have
a doctor
on the other hand there is definitely
data that vaccines have prevented
certain diseases
like polio you know we don't see any
paralysis from polio anymore
just vaccines i think without talking
about just uh general the general
vaccination
well i'd like to hear what dr sema would
say and then i have a follow-up comment
to that
yeah and god bless you for being in your
perspective really seriously you need
people we brought on a medical doctor
and they ask
you know the scholar asked the medical
doctor and he said
we're here to have a heart to heart to
you know get to uh some very
important questions that people have on
the topic
of vaccines in general and i just had a
program
last week and i interviewed one of my
guests this was a
pharmacist by the name of abu isa and we
had a very nice conversation we went
back and forth and i tried to
just be well balanced and present both
sides and just to get
you know some of the things that people
have a hesitancy because
now there's some unanswered question and
they keep hearing certain things
that vaccines are safe you know they're
the best things since peanut butter and
whatnot
so uh what i left off with
was asking him people have a question
regarding
this consensus he said how could we
question this when there's a whole group
of academic science scientists you know
globally
you know that agree to this is it is
this
is this true dr sema
yeah you know you're talking about the
safety right
safety yes of your common vaccines that
we have i'm not even getting to the
the current one yeah you know we know
that the vaccines are safe we do
we do and we
let's put it this way compared to the
disease say if you have to choose
between the disease and you have to
choose between a fever a cough a rash
and some diarrhea
you would take on allergy asthma eczema
add
adhd insulin dependent diabetes and
seizures
you would take that's the trade-off so
so we know safe right because we've
never had a placebo-controlled trial
we know what every ingredient
synergistic toxicity is right
we know what every ingredient is we
really
where did you find that study i'd like
to see that one
we know we don't know we don't know we
don't we don't know that's the point
we make an assumption that just because
we say
safe and effective over and over again
and just because there's a large group
of people who have bought that
that that that assumption is true
that we move that forward and group
think
and make the assumption that it's true
we make the assumption
that the injection of these non-proven
to be safe
compounds with no synergistic toxicity
that we can give multiple vaccines at
the same time
with no synergistic toxicity is going to
be safer
than a fever a cough a rash some
diarrhea
for the vast majority of people who
contract an uh a viral infection
we know that right we know that we don't
know that
doctors
synergistic toxicity is you take one
ingredient alone
and test it and we know from basic high
school chemistry
that you can have three completely inert
compounds sitting on a table and you can
mix all three of those compounds
together
and cause a reaction that could actually
bubble over the top maybe even explode
the test tube
that's synergistic toxicity that one by
itself may be okay
but when you add a whole bunch of
compounds and there are more than 160
different ingredients in the various
vaccines
when you put them all together you may
have an unknown consequence
even with pharmaceutical medications you
can have
active metabolites right you can take a
pill
it can break down in the liver you can
have active metabolites and when you
take
there has never been a study in medicine
and i've been in medicine 35 years i'm
sure a long time like you have a doctor
i'm saying this respectfully that there
has never been
a synergistic toxicity test of even
pharmaceutical
pills of more than two at a time and yet
we
prescribe people to take four five six
medicines and we
really don't know the effects of those
active compounds
and those active metabolites the same is
true with vaccines
now i totally agree with your statement
we are talking about
you know relative if if a person
uh i have seen deaths with are we caught
talking about povet are we talking about
different uh
just regular the regular vaccines just
regular you know the standard
and may i ask you may i ask you doctor
where what kind of a hospital
what's hospital system you work in are
you a pediatric infection or a dog
no i'm adult adult and you work where
i am in illinois uh suburbs hoffman
states
okay is it a big hospital is it like a
level three center
yes it is a big hospital that we have
just for discussion we have discharged
uh
i think 1200 patients just from my
hospital with covet
okay so what happens in big tertiary
hospital centers
it's not a tertiary hospital it's a
community hospital well it's a big
center
yes and i and are you are you hospital
based or office space
a boat okay as you know infectious
diseases is mostly hospital
most hospital right so what i don't at
all
at all just um discount
or toss away
anybody who may have died from an
infection
it happens that's why you're an expert
and that's why we have a specialist in
infectious disease we have that
but by the time someone gets an
infection and ends up in the hospital
ends up in intensive care and requires
your services
we have a very small subset of people
who are the sickest of the sickest
i agree
to the normal infections that happen in
normal kids out in the community
true so you end up god bless you
that you end up in the very sickest of
the six situations
taking care of people that require a
sub-specialist
not just a doctor that can prescribe an
antibiotic or an antiviral
but requires your expertise so you
have a bit of a skewed perspective as a
physician
that you get to see the sickest of the
sick but yet
we would vaccinate everyone down to the
healthiest of the healthy
we inject foreign matter into healthy
children
all the time that would just normally
have
a fever a cough a rash and some diarrhea
and recover
with full lifetime immunity so dr sherry
just sorry just to
kind of ask you on your kind of um
perspective on this what you're saying
that
is your position that we shouldn't uh
vaccinate the healthiest of the society
or is your position that
vaccine altogether are not good
or that we should be vaccinating those
who are the highest risk what's your
exact position well
after 20 years and more than 40 000
hours i'm not sure doctor how many hours
you've spent specifically digging
through the medical literature looking
at problems with vaccines
i've spent 20 years and 40 000 hours on
this
so i didn't just decide two weeks ago
that this was a topic i wanted to talk
about
so so
my position is is that vaccines are not
safe
they don't keep you from getting sick
because you can be fully vaccinated and
contact contract the infection anyways
they do cause harm and sometimes death
and that health is an inside out
phenomenon you know it has to do with
the krebs cycle and all of the different
nutrients that you have
and it has you know it's how you keep
healthy from because we swim
in bugs all day long but we only get
excited about
about bacteria and viruses for which we
have a vaccine
now how many infectious disease cases
doctor do you see that you take care of
they're deathly sick very sick
that we don't have a vaccine for i'm
sure quite a few as an
expert absolutely i think we are i
we are talking about two different
things here
you know are we talking about covet only
or we are we want
a discussion about vaccines just
vaccines i think without talking about
just
uh general the general vaccination just
general general vaccines before even
you know this one uh what's in his trial
stages came out just the regular vaccine
and you know it's how you look at the
situation
as dr sherry is your last name
my last name is 10 penny 10 penny so
absolutely you bet okay
so you know there is a as she said you
know there is literature that you can
spend your life time
reading about complications and side
effects of vaccine and still you won't
be done with it
so you know my my ex my husband who god
rest his soul passed away seven years
ago was a navy pilot
and he he said that there was an
expression in the navy
if there was any doubt this plane was
not gonna was
gonna crash when we if there's any doubt
that this there's
that there's a problem there's no doubt
that we're not gonna fly
so when we've got 30 000
vares reports per year to the vaccine
adverse event reporting system and they
think that's 10 percent
when we have tens of thousands of
children who've been published in
medical literature showing problems with
vaccines
when do we decide that the risk of the
vaccine
and the complications and illnesses that
come from this vaccine
far super exceed this very
small number of children who may
contract that infection and have an
adverse event from it
but when do we weigh that when do we
weigh that sorry
i just wanted to get dr siemens because
we kind of
understand your perspective on the
vaccines now we want to get like
an overall response from dr seymour
where she stands on on the vaccine
discussion
and why it is as
a physician you know we the literature
you can see literature both ways you can
see literature
that you get side effects
and long-term effects from vaccine
and they have data about that
but on the other hand there is
definitely data that vaccines have
prevented certain diseases
like polio you know we don't see any
paralysis from polio anymore any
weakness from polio and as
you can see smallpox is eradicated so
you can argue either ways
and it's it's your choice whether it's
measles as measles another example
yes usually and what was the trade-off
from that
the trade-off from from
first of all polio is still around and
we
but there are more cases every year on
an ongoing basis
of paralysis caused by the vaccine then
paralysis caused by the
endemic infection we've actually
eradicated completely eradicated off the
planet one of the three strains
inside of the polio vaccine but yet we
continue to use
the same vaccine vaccinating for
something that doesn't exist
in the western hemisphere we've had no
polio
since 1991 we've been declared polio
free
there are less than 10 countries in the
world that still have any level of
endemic polio
and yet here in the united states even
though that we are back we're
vaccinating for something that doesn't
exist
we give children four to five doses of
polio vaccine
for a virus that has not existed in the
western hemisphere
since 1991.
all right can i just ask a question here
at this juncture i know i know that
you've
got to have that i don't want to come up
too much but just because a lot of lay
people
especially those who have been obviously
uh
exposed to mainstream narratives let's
say will be given the measles example
[Music]
basically the fact that if you look at
the ratio of people that have been
uh that were dying uh before the measles
vaccine
was two and two and two million kids
were dying per year that's 1963 data
two out of two mil there were two deaths
per million
children that contracted measles the
year before
they started giving the measles vaccine
that's cdc data
so millions and millions of children
dying in america for measles wasn't
happening
sorry will cdc centers for disease
control
so what's the reaction about doctor
sorry doctor doctor my hope my co-host
is from uh from
england from he's from uk so they have a
different one over there dr
they don't know about the cdc oh i see
okay he's from england yeah from london
oh oh you're from england no
i am from a developing country you know
i have seen measles
i have seen polio when uh you know
when i was in training
so if we can get that disease
burdened down with vaccination i think
it's an achievement if we do not have
those cases it's not i think we're not
talking about
uh u.s yes u.s there is low incidence
but still we have seen some cases of
measles
but i agree not everybody dies with
measles but they have been
bad outcomes from measles and children
but we also have
written evidence of people that had
contracted measles as a child like i did
i had
measles mumps rubella pertussis twice i
had all of those things
i think it's one of the reasons i'm a
very healthy adult because my immune
system
was allowed to have fever and exercise
its cytokine reactions at the
appropriate age
now we have evidence that shows that
people who had had
measles at a young age had a much lower
incidence of brain cancer
they have a much lower incidence of
autoimmune diseases
you know measles was always a natural
symbian which means that
we work together for the for not for you
doctor but for the audience
that a symbiotic relationship is that
that was a good thing
that when we had a measles infection
that it burned off the residual
adult pro mother proteins and it locked
in our basement membranes
and in fact in the 1940s children that
had nephrotic syndrome
which is a condition again for the
audience a condition
that the basement membranes of their
kidneys were leaky
and they used to leak proteins and
sometimes if it was a severe case
children could die from that the
treatment for that was to induce
measles they exposed them and when they
had the high fever and had the measles
infection
it sealed those basement membranes and
cured their
nephrotic syndrome we have a symbiotic
relationship with a lot of microbes
we're not just here to get rid of them
i'm just looking at some data now
there's a oxford university has a
website called vaccination knowledge
and i'm just going to read out to you
something that they weren't right i want
you to react to it
they say below the graph below right but
it shows that the reported number of
mutual cases in the uk
between 1940 and 1990 it said before a
vaccine existed
there were often hundreds of thousands
of mutual cases every year
cases cases yeah would you say
in 1967 the year before a vaccine was
first introduced there were 460
407 suspected of disease by the end of
1980s uh vaccinations had brought these
figures down to around 10 000 suspects
one or two yeah and since then middles
have uh
all cases have fallen still further
cases
yeah and it's uh there's mentioned
deaths as well okay so how would
one or two one or two out of there
so our data and it goes all the way back
to 1963 so cases
yeah you have no idea what recovery rate
is
when they report large numbers of cases
cases does not equal death
cases means they had an infection and
all but one or two of those
recovered you know can i ask you guys
uh tell me this this uh this is the
billion dollar question
and recently we also had in our
community we had
some uh people come together and they
brought on a medical doctor and they
asked you know the scholar asked the
medical doctor and he says
does autism does do vaccines cause
autism and then the standard answer is
no it doesn't
so and then you go on the cdc website
and it says the same thing so
how would you guys answer this well i
would say for one thing the cdc was just
forced
to take vaccines do not cause autism off
of their website
it's no longer there because they had to
admit
that it does and it can we've got
adjudicated course cases
plus on the package inserts it actually
describes that vaccine's one of the side
effects is encephalopathy
which means your brain isn't working
correctly right and by definition if
your brain is not working defect
in if your brain's working incorrectly
depending on how severe that
encephalopathy is
it can be diagnosed as autism we've just
learned as a community and as a bunch of
physicians
the knee-jerk reflex about about
vaccines and autism without looking at
the
adjudicated cases through the vaccine
court without looking at the medical
literature
without looking at the sealed
indictments or a sealed document
without looking around at the community
and talking to parents
that have video recordings of their kids
birthday being normal
getting their vaccines and a week later
they've descended into autism
which they do allow that as evidence in
court cases
a lot of cases i mean how how prevalent
is this if we're talking about for
example
a hundred percent of children that have
been vaccinated how many of them
exhibit these uh symptoms well new
jersey
new jersey data is one in 24 kids
one in 24 are on the spectrum
and and we have we've heard data that
have come from dr stephanie sunup who's
a phd out of mit
that if we continue on the same
vaccination schedule with impunity
by 2030 or 2035 the uh the rate of
autism in this country alone we're not
talking in the world this country
will be one in two and of that one
percent of that 50
more than half of those will be boys now
if there's any doubt there's no doubt
and i believe that one of the biggest
problems with the vaccine schedule
is how many that we give at a time
because again it goes back to the goes
back to the synergistic toxicity thing
if we and now children because the
children now get multiple
doses of 17 different vaccines
yeah doctor you said that is
you can find that anywhere i mean
there's there's a lot of data in in the
us i don't have a reference off the top
of my head i haven't looked at
i haven't spent a lot of time on the
autism data lately i've been
my head's kind of been incovid so
i didn't know that was going to be like
a question you know i
but there's one in 24 in new jersey
there's places
that are greater than that i mean
there's that data you can find it's out
there
what about the uh comment comment
comment go ahead mohammed
i think this is one of the biggest
worries that people taking vaccines will
have
that in fact we're talking about five
percent um you know
i'd like to hear what dr sema would say
and then i have a follow-up comment to
that
yeah no i have heard i don't want to
give any numbers
to it but i have heard parents
that as uh sherry mentioned that
they believed that the child was normal
prior to vaccination
do i have any data to back up no but i
have heard personally i'm not talking as
a
infectious disease physician but as
uh as a community member i have heard
that
but have i looked up in it or do i have
any comment about
it no in particular that caused the
autism it can be any of them
i mean we've we've put a lot of emphasis
and a lot of focus on mmr
over the years but it can be you know it
can be dpt
it can be any of them it can be
hepatitis b it can be dpt
it can be any of them i've got a problem
question here some will argue that
this uh tenuous link or this problem
between correlation and causation a lot
of these kids would have been diagnosed
with autism anyway because
growing up autism is not usually
detected in
up until let's say for example a certain
age and so those kids we have no way of
proving
that they wouldn't have had autism had
they not been vaccinated
except except look at the unvaccinated
population what is the incidence of
of autism in the completely unvaccinated
population it's almost as close to zero
as you can get
and why has it that the powers that be
whether it's in the uk
or the cdc or the world health
organization
or or unicef or any of those
organizations
who spend billions and i'm talking tens
of billions maybe even hundreds of
billions of dollars a year
to vaccinate everyone in the world why
have they not set aside a couple million
dollars of that
to do a really well done really well
done
well-designed study to compare the
health of un completely unvaccinated
kids
to kids who are fully vaccinated why
haven't they done that they've refused
to do it it's been requested multiple
times
we have small studies that have been
self-funded to try to show the health of
that
why do they refuse to do it because you
can't find what you're not looking for
and you don't want to show under any
circumstances
that unvaccinated children have an
intact healthy
immune system and are not in the same
category
of asthma allergies eczema ear
infections
um on and on and on seizure disorders
epilepsy
as vaccinated kids they don't want that
data out there
therefore they don't fund studies to do
it
even come close mohammed not even close
let me ask you guys before i know you
got a heart stop coming up in 10 minutes
you and dr sima both this question for
both of you guys i asked
i i wanted just to talk about vaccines
in general we kind of went over here on
this side
uh back to the the billion dollar
question
usually what's brought up and it was
also in this question that was asked to
a scholar to
the to the doctor and the doctor
repeated that uh
no there's no link and then he brought
up what's always brought up is dr
wakefield that he was discredited he's
the one that brought this up
you know about this uh obviously dr sema
dr wakefield and he was discredited and
then that case is closed now what do you
guys have to say
my opinion about that is if your only
defense and your only argument
is a 1998 paper that was pulled
can't you don't you think there may have
been a little bit more research since
then
i think that it's such a lame argument
it's almost laughable
after ever actually read the original
paper he didn't
but it's that's the other reason why
that is such
a lame argument with people who really
don't know the science
and are just trying to use sound bites
to change the dialogue
because they really have no idea what
they're talking about dr simon did you
want to comment
yeah autism you know we
i go by cdc data you know being an
infectious disease physician
so i as i said autism
parents feel strongly about it that
autism is
associated with vaccines but
i see a benefit from vaccine you know
being at this situation at my position i
still feel that vaccines are helpful
but can they have side effects yes
they can they do have side effects
so i think it's the choice of the person
who's taking the vaccine they have to
consider
and the risks and the benefits the
parents
and their parents and the patients you
know dr
dr seaman thank you dr sema thank you so
much for saying that
because that's exactly where it should
be we should not be
mandating any vaccine because the one
it's the one area of medicine
and you would concur with this dr seam i
know you will that it's the when it
comes to vaccination it's the one area
of medicine that we don't take into
consideration
family history individual genetics
we don't take into it you know our food
history what are people eating
what is their lifestyles who is at
greater risk
and you know when you've got two parents
that say hey when i was a kid i had
severe reactions to vaccines you're like
doesn't matter just vaccinate your kid
anyways
it's you know when we take a medical
history as you know
we ask for things like cancer history
autoimmune diseases
seizures do you have a history if you
have a patient that has headaches you
have a family history of migraines
we always want to know what the family
history is does that make you more
susceptible
when it comes to vaccination vaccinating
children
it's the one area of medicine and even
adults
it's the one area of medicine that we
completely ignore
past medical history and family history
so thank you
for saying that it should be a person's
own research and a person's own decision
dr sherry our uh
baseball you know when we were talking
about the deaths the difference between
death and cases
i was able to just pull out something um
and this might be flawed
i mean i'll have to look into the
discussions on this but w
show they say
how can they decrease the number of
deaths when the death rate is 2 per
million i guess they could go to 0.5
i don't know
you know i i think that would be the my
take on the vaccines is yes it decreases
the disease
yes it decreases the death but people
have experienced some side effects and
it should be an informed
decision from you know whoever is
taking the vaccine either the parents or
themselves
agenda vaccinate consensus
sherry my guest this week he kept
pushing the thing about
us being too uh skeptical
and he kept saying how can this be i'm
talking about general vaccines where you
have a global community international
community
a consensus how would you respond to
that i told him that i'd get back to you
and hear your response to that
because i would say that the consensus
the global community the vast majority
of physicians with all due respect to dr
sema
the vast majority of physicians have
just said safe and effective vaccinate
and that's all they've done to look into
any of it
they've memorized the schedule they may
have read
that's it what about the regulatory
agencies what about what about the
regulatory agencies that are there dr
sherry penny they're the global
community also what about them
scientists you know people who are at
that level
i have i have over seven i have over 17
000 papers in my collection
17 000 papers of scientists and
community people
that have shown problems and injuries
associated with vaccines that's not a
one-off
you know anecdotal when you have 17 000
papers
that show problems with each of these
individual vaccines i would just say
that the global community mark schlock's
step because that's what doctors do
they march lockstep they're like a herd
or pack a herd of water buffalo they
move together
and they haven't taken really a deep
dive into any of it
if you can send that uh i know you got
to go i want to we made history here
why is it that we we have finally been
able to put
i mean two together and this is dr sema
what do you think we've been trying to
get i mean you're a brave
soul thank you you are thank you so much
dr sema
we need to we these are the conversation
what do you think muhammad hijab these
conversations are they important
honestly i've i feel much more
elucidated
i feel much more informed now but i feel
like it should be a place
for me to go and do more research
following the numbers and the trails the
data trails that
the two adults have given us and it's
given me a little bit more clarity and i
think a lot of people watching this will
feel the same way
i want to you know because i i really do
have to run but i want to once again
dr sema thank you so much because nobody
ever wants to do this
i mean i've we've tried multiple times
to get
discussions like this and the people who
are pro-vaccine advocates
will say i don't want to have a
discussion because if if there's a
debate
it proves there's something worthy of
debate and you bringing to the table
a healthy discussion you know of both
sides i
really respect that and thank you so
much i hope we can do this again
i wasn't aware this was going to be the
discussion
we made history here have you ever sat
with three muslims like this there's a
lot of misconceptions about
muslims have you ever sat with three
muslims like this
absolutely the first time and thank you
all three of you
god bless you if you ever have any
questions about islam anything
you got look up muhammad hijabs he's one
of the main guys out there educating
people
uh you got me you got dr sema you made
the connection with dr sherry
any data you want to exchange we're here
for you dr sherry and dr sema and vice
versa dr sema this is because this is
where i spend my time
you know if you are like well here's
this thread of data what else is there
i mean i'm happy you can read the
studies yourself i mean the stuff that i
pull out comes from mainstream published
literature it doesn't come from
conspiratorology.com and it doesn't come
from just my opinion
and so if you're interested i can get
them to to
to dean and he can get that on to you
and um
and then there you can then have the
opportunity to really do fully informed
consent with your patients
and a patient say listen i i don't care
what you tell me about the vaccine i
still want to get it
well at least you know and when other
people ask you things like well what's
in it
are there any long-term studies what are
the complications then you can actually
have a full
a really informed answer for them and
thank you again i hope we can do this
again sometime
thank you all thank you very much to
meet you all
thank you
and if you like this episode of the dean
show like this video
share this video far and wide and
support us on our patreon page so we can
continue this work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum
subscribe right now